شريحه ايلون ماسك للادمغه نيرولينج ابتكار
تكنولوجي جديد حصل على موافقه من اداره
الغذاء والدواء لاجراء اول تجربه سريريه
على البشر شريحه يورالينك ستوضع في ادمغه
البشر بهدف السماح للعقل البشري بالتحكم
في الاجهزه الالكترونيه المعقده ومساعده
الاشخاص المصابين بالشلل على استعاده
الوظيفه الحركيه واستعاده الرؤيه لفاقد
البصر وعلاج امراض الدماغ الاخرى هذا يعني
السماح لمن يعانون من انعدام القدره على
الحركه بالتواصل عبر افكارهم الشريحه
الدماغيه تترجم النشاط العصبي الى بيانات
يمكن تفسيرها بواسطه الكمبيوتر
رغم ذلك لا يزال الخبراء يشككون بشان جدوى
هذه الشريحه وقالوا ان الامر اقرب للخيال
العلمي
واجهت فضائح عديده منذ اوائل العام الماضي
من ضمنها اجراء تجارب غير اخلاقيه على
القرود
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات